I must warn you that at some point
during the next 4 days your brain might
explode by then you won't even care it's
time for Ted the Africans are the green
down here they still remain here this is
India Indonesia is moving on pretty fast
and in the 80s here you have Bangladesh
still among the African countries there
but not Bangladesh it's a miracle that
happens in the 80s the Imams start to
promote Family Planning and they move up
into that corner and in 90s we have the
terrible HIV epidemic that takes down
the life expectancy of the African
countries and all the rest of the mall
moves up into the corner where we have
long lives and small family and we have
a completely new world the bacteria we
was had no idea of what we are today and
today we have no idea of what we shall
be in 4 billion years and this territory
is fantastic that it's out poetry it's
just it's just fascinating that every
single person you meet is doing
something incredible and I was thinking
about this what to talk about it Ted
when I talked to the the kind rep from
Ted and I said listen you know what
should I talk about he said don't worry
about it just just be profound
it's the impression you get of just this
huge diversity of expertise and passion
and I've never been to a conference
before where people are actually pushing
people decide to get into the room it's
a normally the other way around you know
people are scrambling to get out
I'm a witness and I want my testimony to
be honest and uncensored I also want it
to be powerful and eloquent and to do as
much justice as possible to the
experience of the people I'm
photographing we have a chance here to
prove that a country that almost
slaughtered itself out of existence can
practice reconciliation and provide
comprehensive quality health care with
minimal outside health being up on the
stage
doesn't matter if it's 350 in the
audience or not it feels like it's
thousands because it really is this
intimidating the crazy space but I got
to tell you it really is a loving
atmosphere people who here want you to
do really well when you're sharing ideas
and suddenly you are more than the font
of the ideas I mean you are like a
preacher and you can almost feel a
transformation them suddenly they're
saying wow this is really interesting
wow this is the most interesting they
haven't heard about well I love this
idea if anybody just stays in their own
little world they miss maybe the right
way to affect the rest of the world when
the experts rise to the challenge of
doing this they actually surprise
themselves they actually learn something
more about their own subject they learn
something more in particular about how
to convey it this opens my eyes to a new
way of articulating something I knew
but I I didn't yet know how to make it
unforgettable Ted is about releasing
power intellectual power emotional power
and the power of contribution in the
world this is the song they played over
the loudspeakers in Tiananmen Square
during the revolution this is the songs
which they played in Berlin when the
wall fell down this is the song to the
possibility that human beings are and I
say that's who you
I guess those of us would have been
around Ted for a while cause things like
this Ted moments
you